hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
as BP makes another massive profit we
look at the oil Giants investments in
green energy
hope for the Amazon after Lula wins the
Brazilian election on a green ticket
[Music]
and signs of a false spring as a baking
summer and warm Autumn full many trees
into budding early
foreign
thanks for joining us on the daily
climate show where we track the changes
to our world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now BP today became the latest
oil producer to announce bumper third
quarter profits thanks to Soaring gas
and oil prices because of the war in
Ukraine the company made 7.1 billion
pounds during the three months more than
doubled for the same period last year
but BP insists the company is focused on
Beyond petroleum and says it will be Net
Zero by 2050 and as soon as 2030 for
some areas of the business so just how
is it going to manage that well BP says
it has increased investment in
Renewables from 433 million pounds in
2019 to 1.9 billion in 2021.
and plans to raise that further to
between 3.5 to 5.2 billion pounds by
2030. the company says it's investing 10
billion pounds in offshore wind projects
in Scotland
that is part of a one billion pound
investment in the UK over the next 10
years it has pledged to travel its BP
pulse electric car charging points by
2030.
now despite those promises from BP there
are growing calls for a windfall tax on
oil Giants including one from the cop 26
president Alex Sharma who tweeted today
saying as I said last week we need to
raise more money from a windfall tax on
oil and gas companies and actively
encourage them to invest in Renewables
foreign
our business presenter Ian King who is
in the city for us so Ian just how green
are BP's credentials well they're
certainly more green than a lot of their
International peers and particularly the
big American integrated oil and gas
companies like Exxon and Chevron you
could say that both BP and uh shell are
far more investing far more heavily in
Renewables than the likes of their
American counterparts all of whom are
much more profitable I should say
Chevron has just reported a quarterly
profit of 11.2 billion US Dollars uh
Exxon has just reported a quarterly
profit of 20 billion dollars so
significantly higher than the 8.15
billion dollars that BP has just
reported I mean you mentioned some of
the highlights there I mean in the
latest quarter they've completed an
investment in a big green hydrogen
project in Australia and the pilbara
region of Western Western Australia
which is expected to be one of the
biggest such projects in the world
they've also invested in a green
hydrogen uh project in t side in this
country which again is one of the
largest of its kind and BP pulse the
charging Network to which you referred
well the number of charging points for
electric vehicles that BP has got
operating now is up some 60 on this time
last year so you could argue they're
making pretty rapid progress in that
sense the key headline numbers you've
got to look at is that by 2025 BP say
that 40 of all their capital expenditure
is going to be on low carbon and
renewable projects and by the end of the
decade it will represent 50 percent of
all capital expenditures so they are
pivoting a very pretty rapidly away from
traditional fossil fuel activities and
you'll recall of course more than a year
ago Bernard Looney the chief executive
made clear that BP would actually be
leaving some of the oil and gas reserves
that it owns in the ground because it
wants to concentrate on those low carbon
operations on the point of a windfall
tax well it's actually very very
debatable that the government can go
much further than it has the Chief
Financial Officer Murray Hocking class
today making the point that for every
three dollars BP currently makes in the
North Sea two dollars of that goes
straight to the UK government already in
terms of uh how they're taxed compared
with some of their U.S counterparts BP
and show are already pretty heavily
taxed
all right and many thanks indeed
and let's look at some other climate
news today shall we a survey has
revealed that more than 70 percent of
drivers have been deterred from owning
an electric vehicle because of increases
in Energy prices the poll conducted by
the AAA showed a further 63 percent said
the cost of electricity has made them
more reluctant to buy an electric car in
Australia heavy rain has caused flash
flooding in a number of areas some
residents of New South Wales were forced
to evacuate their homes with police
currently looking for two people who
disappeared in flood waters flooding
across Australia has killed more than 20
people this year events that experts say
are becoming more frequent due to
climate change
and the tree Council says the unusually
warm weather in the summer has led to
evidence of a false spring taking place
these are extremely rare and occur when
plants are tricked into blooming early
by radical weather swings this all comes
as temperatures past 40 degrees celsius
you recall for the first time ever
during the summer heat wave something
the Met Office says is virtually
impossible without human-induced climate
change the charity charity says it has
observed leaves browning early and
flowers emerging on trees around the
south of England it's asking for people
to send in examples they have had
so kirst armor has struck an optimistic
note ahead of the cop 27 Summit which
starts this Sunday the labor leader
insisted that successfully tackling the
climate crisis will provide the biggest
opportunity in decades to make the
economy deliver for working people let's
bring in our chief political
correspondent John Craig who is in
Westminster so still great deal of
uncertainty whether Rishi sunak himself
is going to go to Egypt's John is Zakir
starmer trying to steal a march here
well the latest from number 10 is that
whether or not Mr sunat goes to the cop
27 Summit in Egypt and charmel Sheikh
that is under review to use their words
and yes uh the labor leader sir Kia
stammer is turning up the heat on the
governments on green policies we heard
uh this uh from him at the labor Party
Conference a few weeks ago setting out
what he calls his green Prosperity plan
a 28 billion pound a year investment
plan for a green economy labor insiders
tell me that uh this plays well with
focus groups popular with voters so
Sakira has been speaking to Business
Leaders at a Gala dinner last night in
which he said uh optimistically there's
no need for gloom the way I see it this
is the biggest opportunity we've had in
decades to make the country work for
working people he's talking about
creating jobs Industries businesses of
the future and cheaper bills for working
people and and he says real independence
from tyrants like Putin and their fossil
fuel economic weapons so Mr sakir is
talking about he says we need to win the
race for electric car batteries quantum
computers personalized medicines he says
we also need to support the small
traders who replace our car batteries
the it firms who get our offices running
smoothly the pharmacies who sell
medicine in our communities and expect
to hear a lot more of this from Cirque
both during cop in the week or so ahead
and between now and the next general
election as labor attempts to play the
Green Card all right John thanks a lot
Brazil's president-elect Louis serasio
de Silva is to send representatives to
Egypt for cop 27 even though he will not
be inaugurated himself until New Year's
Day the Electoral win for Lula as Mr de
Silva is known has been hailed as a
victory for the Amazon after a massive
increase in deforestation under his
predecessor Jaya bolsonaro our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey reports from
Sao Paulo
the exploitation of the Amazon
rainforest was a key strategy of
President bolsonaro and it resonated
with truckers loggers and farmers
deforestation under bolsonaro increased
every year to record levels Farmers got
rich the indigenous forest dwellers lost
their lands and Lula says all that is
going to stop
environmentalists say the changes must
be quick he has come to that
and yesterday at the police
this is actually the argument we have to
say we have no time left it has to be
done now
foreign
[Applause]
the election win for Lula signaled the
start of an enormous Street party as
world leaders sent a swathe of
congratulatory messages and phone calls
but the new leader has a lot to do Lula
has an awful lot of issues on his plate
that he has to address straight away one
is obviously the Amazon will will get a
huge amount of international support
he's promising to change all of
bolsonaro's policies on the Amazon and
save the forest which we'll get as I say
huge support abroad and by a lot of
people here the other one though he has
to address is poverty it is a real big
problem here he's promising huge amount
of spending on social housing and
education it's a huge huge job though
Stuart Ramsey now just before we go a
reminder that ahead of cop27 starting on
Sunday our weekly climate Show with Tom
Heap is back from this weekend you can
watch it on Saturdays and Sundays at 3
30 in the afternoon or at 7 30 in the
evening
that's it from the daily climate show
thank you for your company do join us
again tomorrow goodbye
[Music]